mal gucken das ist wirklich die
spannende frage wie viel druck der
bundespräsident noch auf die großen
parteien macht er ist jedenfalls
eindeutig der mann der stunde
deswegen schalten wir jetzt mal live ans
schloss bellevue in berlin zu albrecht
humboldt albrecht entscheidet
steinmeiers überzeugungs talent jetzt
die zukunft deutschlands absolut oliver
ja wer hätte gedacht dass ein deutscher
bundespräsident mal regelrecht arbeiten
muss normalerweise stehst du da um 11
uhr auf übernimmt die schirmherrschaft
für irgendein krötentunnel und dann
legst du dich wieder hin
aber diese woche hatte frank weiter
wirklich den termin seines lebens es
stand so viel auf dem spiel
aber er hat es super gemacht er steigt
fehlerfrei aus dem auto aus und dann
begrüßt er die knie ja mit verbeugung
genau tief genug nicht zu tief ihr prinz
william ganz alte schule sagt hallo
hitler wer sind sie toll
die clean übrigens in einem flamingo
farbenen kostüm von pimkie wunderbar
waren sie auch so aufgeregt die
steinmeiers am dienstag zum lunch im
buckingham palace
es gab damit - das ist ja ekelhaft
albrecht ich meinte den termin gestern
mit seehofer merkel und schulz wegen
staatskrise und so gott die langweilige
scheiße also wirklich die krise hätten
wir doch gar nicht mit einer anständigen
monarchie sage ich seit jahren es war
ein riesenfehler den kaiser so
überstürzt ins exil zu schicken
albrecht ich weiß nicht waren lange
adelsexperte beim mdr und sind ein
großer fan der inzucht aber doch noch
mal ernsthaft kann steinmeier seiner
alten partei spd wirklich zur groko
raten ja nein keine ahnung ist mir egal
wie ich diese ganzen bürgerlichen pseudo
probleme anhören
mit wem regierten merkel das ist doch
völlig dunkel welche partei der ewige
hosenanzug als nächstes frist können wir
uns nicht einfach mal freuen über die
schönen dinge im leben
prinz harry hat sich verloren ich bin
außer mir vor freude und sehr froh dass
es heute nicht regnet auf die frage wer
denn den heiratsantrag gemacht habe
antwortete harry da nur ausweichen
das erzähle ich ein andern mal nein nein
ich bis jetzt wissen welche das volk
braucht ablenkung gerade in krisenzeiten
warum haben wir so was nicht okay idee
um den bürgern doch noch die gruppe
schmackhaft zu machen
verbinden sich zwei alte deutsche
adelshäuser das haus bayern mit dem
willy brandt haus markus söder heiratet
andrea nahles
das braucht wirklich kein mensch doch
doch doch das wäre super
allerdings müssten sich die beiden
bayern ja genau wie harry und merken da
tickt zumindestens beim england bisschen
die biologische uhr
sie ist 36 ja da muss man sich schon
einen tacken bei allen ja merken ist 36
die hat vielleicht noch eine handvoll
royale sprünge aber dann ist schicht im
schacht
oliver zeug die zeit weg das stimmt
albrecht und meine damen und herren
fehlern